so donald trump did more than a dozen
rallies over the last few days he's
going crazy going
11 a.m to 11 p.m doing rallies in the
dark and the cold and the heat in the
wind complaining about all of the
weather at every single one of these
we've learned that these rallies are not
without negative effect
we've seen old folks get hypothermic
after being left at the rallies with no
buses to take them back to their cars
we've seen folks get heat stroked as
they start just spraying water onto
crowds in the extreme heat and sun
stanford study which i will talk about
has found that at least 700 people have
died of coronavirus
thanks to donald trump's rallies and it
is all about
feeding his ego if you are delusional or
whacked enough to even go to one of
these rallies during a pandemic
you're voting for trump he's not
convincing anybody
he's feeding his ego and just some of
the most insane things from the last
couple of days here
i can't cover at all it wouldn't be
healthy to expose you
to all of it but i'm going to play a few
clips for you from the different rallies
trump here actually saying out loud what
his philosophy has been which is
whatever obama did i will do the
opposite
frankly we just said what did obama do
and i heard
and you know what i did i did the
opposite i said what did obama do
and then i did the opposite then it
worked
now there's one thing that's missing
there which is everything obama did he
will undo
unless it's something he wants credit
for in which case trump will just claim
he did it obama protected pre-existing
conditions with obamacare
oh i protected pre-existing conditions
or i will
what obama did veterans choice we did
veterans choice
just say i did it that's the piece that
was missing there
trump then continuing to glorify mob
violence
the surrounding of a joe biden bus and
the sideswiping of a staff vehicle trump
loves it
they had the thing with these really i
think
very good people they were riding along
the highway
and you had sleepy joe's bus
so they escorted the bus and the radical
left said oh what a horrible thing that
is to escort the bus
they don't tell you about antifa that go
around burning down your cities
democrat run only democrat wrong
they don't talk about that bopping
people over the head killing people
extremely dangerous and we did an entire
segment on that so i won't
rehash it here uh then donald trump now
at a different rally donald trump says
you know if biden wins we're not going
to have anything
biden's going to he's been saying biden
will take away
electricity and indoor heating and
cooling
now he has another list of things joe
biden will take away
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduation no weddings
no thanksgiving no christmas no easter
no fourth of july
no future for american youth other than
that he's doing quite a good job right
the reality is all of those things have
happened
under trump due to his mishandling of
coronavirus
remember guys in march when trump said
let's do two weeks
two weeks of washing hands and then
we're gonna reopen on easter it's gonna
be amazing
it's trump's mishandling that led to
this it's a level of projection that in
this
uh this close to the end of the campaign
is just beyond words
it's an authoritarian nightmare as well
donald trump during one of his corona
rallies over the weekend
not accepting that there will be a
peaceful transition of power if he loses
and now they say will you respect the
decision of the voters
and will there be a friendly transition
first of all there's not going to be a
transition we're winning
but then you say then you say well
let me ask you four years ago was there
a friendly transition
they were spying on my campaign before i
even won
and what was worse was they were spying
on my campaign
after i won to overthrow the president
of the united states okay which is
called treason
which is called treason and let's see
what the hell happens i don't know why
it takes so long but it takes a long
time
trump still will not say there will be a
transition
we now know thanks to the report from
axios at the top of the show
that the trump plan is in any scenario
other than a biden blowout
donald trump will step up to a podium
and declare victory tomorrow night
and instead here he's saying you know
the real problems
are the crimes committed by barack obama
which of course
he still can't actually enumerate we've
slid
into authoritarianism it's happened
slowly over four years
if trump had started with this four
years ago it would have been
wow but just like we've been warning
about normalization
it's a little bit a little bit a little
bit and now trump regularly calls for
the
imprisonment of his political enemies of
barack obama joe biden hillary
and it makes news but it is not the
unilateral
outrage the unanimous outrage that it
should be we've all become desensitized
to it to some degree
continuing donald trump then fabricated
a meeting
which he then said was a phone call with
prime minister from japan shinzo abe
the call never happened people just
shrug it's not even remarkable that
trump is now making up phone calls that
didn't happen
and you will eviscerate your auto
industry
it will be terrible we can't do it you
know we've worked very hard to bring it
back
i met with prime minister abby of japan
great guy
since retired he had a problem with
health
and uh but fantastic man and i said no
shinzo you have to send plants to
michigan you have to send plants to the
united states and he said no no no i
cannot do that that is a private
decision i said shinzo you're a powerful
man i'm sure you could do it
no no no i said you have to do it shinzo
because you're making too many cars
sending them here
we want to made in the united states you
have to do it he says well i can't the
next day they announced there were five
companies
moving to michigan
japan that was japan he was he's a great
guy that one i'll tell you
not only that that phone call never
happened five companies uh that make
cars didn't move into michigan either it
is all
made up saturday night donald trump was
in pennsylvania
he again floated this idea of obama and
biden committed crimes
the crowd chants lock them up we still
don't know what are the crimes
look at big tech you look at what's been
happening lately right you look at the
media where they refuse to cover one of
the biggest scandals no but the biggest
scandal is
we caught them spying on our campaign
right we caught them trying to overthrow
a duly elected commonly known as me
president of the united states let's see
what happens let's see what happens
very dishonest people
you're right well that you're right you
know
there are a lot of people that call that
treason okay that's crazy
let's see what happens the people for
law and order
and due process right say
lock people up who haven't even been
accused of a crime
trump still struggling with a lot of
words minneapolis continues to
evade him and then portland we want to
go into portland so badly
take out the anarchists it would take us
about 25 minutes
you saw what happened in minneapolis you
know after a week and a half they could
have called
they could have called a little quicker
like not the only instance you know
maybe just avoid saying minneapolis if
you can't say it one more
and don't forget they've done a terrible
job in minnesota where they let
minneapolis burn
down and then here is donald trump
saying ridiculously that under joe biden
i mentioned this you won't have heating
in the winter
you won't have air conditioning in the
summer biden has vowed to abolish the
entire
u.s oil industry no fracking no mining
no natural gas no heating in the winter
no air conditioning in the summer no
electricity during peak hours
do his followers believe that i read an
interesting piece over the weekend
catching up on my reading as it were
that suggests
even trump's followers don't literally
believe when trump says things like
there will be no heating and cooling
under joe biden
but they are okay with it because they
just
write it off as this is how politics
works hyperbole
and lies which is problematic because it
normalizes it which is the exact
opposite of what we need it should be
ostracized not normalized
and then just to wrap up the insanity at
an earlier daytime rally
in newtown pennsylvania donald trump
just after we set a record of 100
000 coronavirus cases in a single
24-hour period
donald trump repeats that we are
rounding the turn
and just doing great on the virus we're
ready
we'll have that and we will have it but
even if you didn't i say when i say it
drives them crazy we're rounding the
turn
we're rounding that turn we're rounding
it
and our economy went down less than any
economy anywhere in the world
and it went up faster by far you know
they keep hearing about europe
europe europe well they're not doing
nearly as well seniors will be
first in line for the vaccine and the
vaccine will be free
because it's not their fault it was
china's fault
china did this to us we have to make
sure
we have to i'm not saying it's going to
happen but
we can make it happen we have to be at
the end of these rallies
trump will do a few rallies today trump
may do a few rallies later this week
while the votes are still being counted
we must make sure that by the end of
this week these rallies are over forever
we don't have a choice it's it's a
desperate
desperate situation we'll have more
clips and coverage
on our instagram page at david pakman
show for a much needed break
from the politics how about coffee
follow me on instagram david.pakman
for my slo-mo espresso shot
from this morning the politics still
matter but just for like a 15-second
break you can find that on my instagram
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor
on call each doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you
you get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests
as an example you don't need insurance
it's only 99 bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video